WE WILL WEIGH IN IN A UNIQUE
WAY.
BUT FIRST, WE BEGIN TONIGHT WITH
THE BIG GUY.
JOE BIDEN.
THAT'S HOW JOE WAS IDENTIFIED BY
HIS SON'S BUSINESS PARTNERS IN
COMMUNICATIONS FOUND ON THE
HUNTER BIDEN LAP TOP FROM HELL.
IN FACT, HUNTER'S PARTNERS
MENTIONED THE PLAN TO SET ASIDE
10% FOR THE BIG GUY.
THESE EMAILS REFERENCED BY "THE
WALL STREET JOURNAL" AND "THE
NEW YORK POST" AND "THE
WASHINGTON POST" AND NEW YORK
MAGAZINE AND ALMOST EVERY OTHER
OUTLET IN THE COUNTRY IN AMERICA
REVEAL A HIGHLY UNETHICAL GET
RICH QUICK SCHEME WHERE THE
BIDEN FAMILY COLLECTED MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS FROM SKETCHY FOREIGN
NATIONALS ALL OVER THE WORLD,
USING HUNTER, WHO HAD PRETTY
MUCH ZERO EXPERIENCE TO LEAD THE
WAY.
NOW, KEEP IN MIND, SHADY FOREIGN
NATIONALS, THEY WEREN'T SAY
PAYING MILLIONS OF DOLLARS FOR
HUNTER'S BUSINESS EXPERTISE.
HE WAS WELL KNOWN TO BE
UNSTABLE.
ALSO A DRUG USER, ADDICT, AND
HAD A LOT OF SERIOUS PROBLEMS.
IN FACT, EMAILS THAT WERE
REVIEWED BY THE BUSINESS INSIDER
FROM 2015, THEY ACTUALLY SHOW
THAT ONE POTENTIAL BUSINESS
PARTNER DETAILED THE PROS AND
CONS ABOUT PAYING HUNTER BIDEN
$2 MILLION FOR A PROJECT
INVOLVING THE COUNTRY OF LIBYA.
QUOTE, HUNTER'S NEGATIVES ARE
HE'S AN ALCOHOLIC, DRUG ADDICT,
KICKED OUT OF THE ARMY FOR
COCAINE, CHASING LOW-CLASS
HOOKERS, IS CONSTANTLY NEEDS
MONEY AND MANY MORE HEADACHES.
HE TRAVELS WITH DAD.
HE'S CONNECTED EVERYWHERE IN
EUROPE AND ASIA AND HAS HIGH
ACCESS TO THE HIGHEST LEVELS IN
CHINA.
HE WASN'T SELLING EXPERIENCE, HE
DIDN'T HAVE EXPERTISE.
HE WAS BY EVERY OBJECTIVE
MEASURE SELLING NOTHING BUT
ACCESS AND HE HAS ZERO
EXPERIENCE ACCORDING TO EMAILS
ON HIS OWN LAP TOP.
TALKING ABOUT A LOT OF MONEY FOR
POPS.
THE FORMER FIRST LADY OF MOSCOW,
THE UKRAINIAN OIL AND GAS GIANT
AND THE $1 BILLION BECAME A $1.5
BILLION DEAL WITH THE BANK OF
CHINA.
SO WHY ARE WE TALKING ABOUT THIS
TONIGHT?
WELL, ACCORDING TO "THE
WASHINGTON POST," HUNTER HAS NOW
HIGH-POWERED ATTORNEYS AND ALL
OF THEM IN SEVERAL TOP
DEMOCRATIC STRATEGISTS, THEY
HAVE CREATED THE EQUIVILANT LEBT
OF A POLITICAL WAR ROOM AND THEY
WILL BE INVOLVED TO SLANDER,
BESMIRCH, OR SUE ANYONE WHO
SHINES A LIGHT ON THE SHADY
ACTIVITIES, INCLUDING MEMBERS OF
THE NEW HOUSE REPUBLICAN
MAJORITY LIKE CONGRESSMAN COMBER
AND JIM JORDAN WHO WILL JOIN US
IN A MINUTE.
AND IT INCLUDES THOSE WHO
OBSERVED THE BIDEN FAMILY'S
MALFEASANCE LIKE FORMER BUSINESS
PARTNER TONY BOBALENSKI AND THE
OWNER OF THE REPAIR SHOP WHERE
HUNTER ABANDONED THE LAPTOP.
AND AS JONATHAN TURLEY POINTED
OUT, THIS IS A MOVE TO
INTIMIDATE WITNESSES.
MEMBERS OF THE MEDIA WHO DARE TO
COVER THE STORY MAY ALSO BE
TARGETED BY THE BIDEN CAMP.
SUPPOSEDLY ACCORDING TO THE
ARTICLE POSSIBLY THEY WILL BE
THE SUBJECT OF LAWSUITS.
LET ME BE CLEAR.
WE HAVE ASKED HUNTER BIDEN FOR
COMMENT OVER AND OVER AND OVER
AGAIN, REGARDING HIS ACTIVITIES
AND HIS INVOLVEMENT.
HE AND HIS TEAM STEADFASTLY
REFUSEDED TO GET BACK WITH US.
I WILL GIVE HUNTER BIDEN A WHOLE
WEEK OF PROGRAMMING IF HE WANTS
TO COME ON THE SHOW AND INCLUDE
15 HOURS OF NATIONALLY
SYNDICATED RADIO ON 700 RADIO
STATIONS.
HE NEVER ONCE DENIED THE
AUTHENTICITY OF THE LAPTOP OR
ANY OF THE CONTENTS.
HE HAS NOT REFUTED OUR REPORTING
OR ANYONE ELSE IN THE MEDIA IN
ANY WAY WE'VE SEEN.
ON THE OTHER HAND, THE DISHONEST
FATHER, THE BIG GUY, HAS DENIED
ANY INVOLVEMENT WITH THE SON'S
BUSINESS ACTIVITIES AND HE
CLAIMED OVER AND OVER AGAIN, WE
PLAYED IT MANY TIMES, THAT HE
NEVER HAD A SINGLE CONVERSATION
WITH HIS SON ABOUT HIS FOREIGN
BUSINESS DEALINGS.
ALL OF THAT DESPITE PHOTOGRAPHIC
EVIDENCE SHOWING JOE BIDEN WITH
MANY OF HIS SON'S FOREIGN
BUSINESS PARTNERS, INCLUDING
THAT PICTURE RIGHT THERE IN
FRONT OF YOU, WITH FORMER PRIME
MINISTER OF KAZAKHSTAN.
AND BY THE WAY, THIS PICTURE
WITH MEXICO'S MOST WELL
CONNECTED BUSINESSMAN, AND THIS
PICTURE JOE AND HUNTER GOLFING
FROM THE BOARD MEMBER OF
BURISMA, THE OIL AND GAS GIANT
THAT PAID HUNTER MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS.
HE WENT ON GOOD MORNING,
AMERICA.
EXPERIENCE IN OIL?
NO, GAS?
NO.
ENERGY?
NO?
UKRAINE?
NO.
WHY BEING PAID MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS?
MAYBE BECAUSE OF YOUR FATHER.
WE KNOW JOE BIDEN DID NOT TELL
THE TRUTH ABOUT TALKING TO HIS
SON ABOUT BUSINESS DEALINGS BUT
51 INTEL EXPERTS WERE HAPPY TO
BOLSTER THE CLAIMS.
THEY'RE THE ONES THAT SIGNED ON
TO THE LETTER THAT DISCREDITED
THE HUNTER LAPTOP STORY AS
HAVING THE CLASSIC EARMARKS OF
RUSSIAN INFORMATION, A RUSSIAN
INFORMATION OPERATION.
THEY KNEW BETTER BUT FOR THEM
GETTING JOE BIDEN ELECTED,
THAT'S WHAT REALLY MATTERED.
NOW KEVIN McCARTHY IS PROMISING
TO ISSUE SUBPOENAS TO ALL 51
INTEL EXPERTS TO FIND OUT
EXACTLY WHAT ROLE THEY PLAY IN
CENSORING THE SCANDAL ALONG WITH
BIG TECH AS WE'VE BEEN
DISCUSSING JUST WEEKS BEFORE THE
2020 ELECTION.
OTHER TOP REPUBLICANS HAVE
PREPARED TO ISSUE CRIMINAL
REFERRALS IN THE HUNTER BIDEN
PROBE IF WARRANTED.
THAT DID NOT STOP HUNTER FROM
WALKING UP TO KEVIN McCARTHY AND
HIS MOM AT A STATE DINNER
EARLIER THIS MONTH AND SAY
HELLO.
IT WAS NICE OF HIM.
NOW DESPITE A FEDERAL CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION, A FORTHCOMING
HOUSE INVESTIGATION, AND THE
LEGITIMATE CLAIMS ABOUT PUBLIC
CORRUPTION, HUNTER IS ALWAYS
POPPING UP AT OFFICIAL WHITE
HOUSE EVENTS.
AND THIS IS BECAUSE HUNTER AND
THE SPIRE BIDEN FAMILY BELIEVED
THEY'RE UNTOUCHABLE.
THEY THINK THEY'RE ABOVE THE
LAW.
AND NOW THEY'RE FLAUNTING IT, OR
AT LEAST THAT'S HOW THEY'RE
TRYING TO COME ACROSS IN PUBLIC.
IN REALITY, THE BIDEN CAMP SEEMS
RATTLED.
THE LEGAL TEAM IS REPORTEDLY IN
A STATE OF DISARRAY AND THE NEW
POLITICAL WAR ROOM WREAKS OF
DEATH PRAGS.